on the pavement at the spot where
stephen lawrence was murdered
a memorial plaque to the teenager who
lost his life in such horrific
circumstances more than 27 years ago
his death had ramifications well beyond
the understandable trauma and heartache
suffered by his family and friends but
the protracted criminal investigation
is now effectively at an end scotland
yards commissioner
said all identified lines of inquiry had
now been completed
i do regret that we have not got to the
stage where
all the people who were involved in that
dreadful attack have been
brought to justice and i recognise that
mistakes were made
in the early days although police
believe five young men were directly
involved in the attack on stephen
lawrence
there has only ever been one successful
prosecution
eight years ago where two men gary
dobson and david norris
were convicted of murder reacting to the
news of an end to the active
investigation
stephen's father neville lawrence said i
had hoped that the conviction
of two of the killers in 2012 would lead
to new evidence coming to light
and a prosecution of the other suspects
doreen lawrence appealed to anyone with
information
to still come forward even after many
years
she said it is never too late to give a
mother justice
for the murder of her son whilst the
metropolitan police have given up
i never will the tragedy brought about a
fundamental review
of policing in particular with the
mcpherson report
branding the metropolitan police
institutionally racist
what the report highlighted was the
level of racism in the organization
the met had policies procedures the way
it worked
the way it would it dealt with
investigations
was prejudicial and i think there was
some
very very uncomfortable things that the
met had to accept and was prepared to do
things differently
although police have indicated they
could still reopen the investigation
if they receive credible new evidence
the lawrence family know that the
passage of time
means it is now highly unlikely anyone
else will be brought to justice
for ending a promising young life almost
three decades ago
mark white sky news